At my last lab draw, I had my cholesterol, my thyroid, my cancer tour markers, and so on
tested. I am due for another one done on March 10th. I'm wondering if I should have all
these same things tested again. I'm also struggling with hot flashes and night sweats.
Let's talk about that. Second, so back to this question. Should I have all these things
tested again? Why not? Unless cost is a factor for you, then I would just go and test them
all. So yes, I would just do them all. Also struggling with hot flashes and night sweats.
So hot flashes and night sweats really could they be a function of thyroid? Maybe. Hot flashes
and night sweats are going to be more a function of your estrogen and progesterone hormones not
as much with your thyroid. So if you want to get some more insight into that, you really
need to do a Dutch test and you can order that right on our website. This is an acronym
for a dried urine hormone test. And this is the best and really the only way to really test
all your hormones. So we do a Dutch complete precision labs. And I think that's the most accurate
and researched a lab out there that's performing the Dutch test. It really gives you a really
nice breakdown of all your estrogen progesterone metabolites.
I've heard that you refer to adaptogens and wonder what exactly to order. Maybe if you're
not going to do the Dutch test, then it'd be good to do another cheek swap test to see what
adaptogens would be best for you unless you want to just try some multiple adaptogens in the
store, probably for hot flashes and having them at night, if you're just going to give a product
to try, I would try the core to clear and take that before you go to bed.